Ronnie did an autograph signing at the
bull ring Las Vegas Motor Speedway
before the Star Nursery 150 race
whatever that is and I don't care I
drove the pace car also and he drove the
pace car I swear to God this is a true
story I'm looking at this um promo sheet
to announce Ronnie's appearance I went
who the [ __ ] is this movie star it was a
picture of Ronnie from 15 [ __ ] years
ago when his hair was dark and he had no
he didn't have that big [ __ ] mustache
and he looked good I'm sure the people
who showed up at the racetrack were like
well where's Ronnie we came here to see
this movie star Ronnie looking for this
guy yeah all right stop it
yeah did anyone show up looking for your
autograph or were well I did I did the
autograph session with uh some of the
drivers in the race
with Kurt I did it with Kurt what do you
sign a piece of paper no it was it
photos that actually took the one you
saw on the on the screen there oh the
one from 15 years ago like what do you
don't have a scary picture in their
house right sure you mean Ronnie they
come up to you and they and they go
who's the guy in the picture right
because I mean you look drastically now
if they don't say any they didn't say
anything like that they just really say
thank you and they keep on walking you
know do you write any of like do you
write 69 Ronnie a little more driving no
nothing or [ __ ] well you know
catchphrases
some tits I signed four dildos in a
picture hey how many uh eight by tens
did you sign how many uh pictures uh
almost the whole box I don't know how
many were in there well that was a
successful appearance I guess huh well
of course Kurt was the big deal because
you know he's the big you know NASCAR
driver so he was the big deal there he
actually does something right yeah
exactly well I think it was like they
might have thought yep that must be the
guy who drove the first car you know
like
Rodney was there when they invented the
tire yeah yeah my social security card
is 69. get it I think a lot of people go
to these events they're like hey that
guy over there is giving out pictures
and you know and I don't even think they
question I think they just go hey look
at that guy over there he's giving out
pictures I'm gonna get me one and I
don't even think they know who Ronnie is
and then he must be famous he's got a
picture whose picture did you just get I
don't know I'm gonna go home and figure
it out later I just know it must have
been important he was standing right
next to Kurt Bush himself oh no it's
Kurt's dad
you're saying that's Kurt Busch's dad oh
man see if you can get me yeah people
were all excited when they saw around
you're like Hey look it's Henry Ford the
inventor of the automobile go get his
picture
uh